let's move on though shall we because as
we were hearing earlier new research
shows plastic packaging on supermarket
shelves has been cut by 10
over the past three years but is it
enough and whose responsibility should
it be to reduce the use of plastics so
mike a 10 cut in plastic packaging are
you impressed or are you disappointed
well it's worth having but in the scheme
of things we need to do a lot more
overall plastic production is is going
up uh still and if you if you now look
at all the discarded plastic in the
world that's all happened virtually all
happened over just the last 50 years
if it was cling film it would be enough
to wrap the planet up in this stuff
about one and a half times over and we
have no idea whatever how to ever get
this stuff out of our ecosystem again in
time it breaks into smaller and smaller
pieces but it just turns up in the most
remote parts of the ecosystem and as far
as we know it'll be it'll be pretty well
there for all time so you know it seems
such a simple thing go to the
supermarket you buy something in a
plastic packaging and you and somehow
you don't look after it properly and it
ends up being trashed and discarded into
the ecosystem and actually just think
about it it is there forever so this is
a huge thing that we need to make um you
know faster change on them than we are
at the moment it's good we've seen a
little bit of change so far
so do we need some plastic packaging in
order to keep food fresh to give
consumers the chance to
hang onto their food for a bit
longer well actually i think anna um
that we need to talk about really who's
responsible for the amount of plastic
packaging in our supermarkets and you
know i think it's really commendable
when individual customers who have the
time and the budget to choose products
that come with less packaging make those
choices but actually you know there are
certain industries that are really
driving the expansion of plastics and
the oil and gas industry is again one of
those industries that sees its future in
increasing the market for plastic
production as people stop needing to put
you know oil in their cars
petrochemicals are the big alternative
new market for their products and what
we really need to do is make sure that
we're regulating those companies
ensuring that they're not lobbying
against environmental regulation
including on plastic packaging for
example i think rather than continuing
to put the onus on individual consumers
to make the right choice you know often
difficult circumstances i just want to
get right to get to respond to that do
you think it is governments regulating
businesses that's the answer here micro
of individuals got a part to play
well people ask is it this group or is
it that group and actually it's all
groups so individuals can do something
about this by choosing which products
they buy and which shops they go to
but the shops themselves especially the
supermarkets for example you know have a
huge responsibility to
uh look at their supply chains and get
the plastic out of their packaging and
there's tons and tons that can be done
on that and just by the way that's not
letting the governments off the hook
they can do an awful lot through
regulation as well between those three
sources of pressure we can get rapid
change